come on back to the year 1995 where the
internet came in cereal boxes and i
didn't have to pay rent to live in my
parents basement
it's also the year mortal kombat was
released spending three weeks at the top
of the box office and making over 122
million
fast forward 26 years later and warner
brothers hopes to reboot this struggling
franchise after the disaster that was
mortal combat annihilation
you're alive too bad you
will die so in this video i thought it
would be fun to compare the original
1995 mortal kombat to the 2021 version
what's different what's the same and why
didn't goro get punched in the dick
got to hurt i don't care where you're
from so make sure to like and subscribe
because here
we go right off the bat we have our
first difference the warner brothers
logo you won't see this on the 95
version as it was distributed by
new newline whereas newline only acted
as the production company for the 2021
release
remember that boppin techno mix from the
original
[Music]
well it doesn't quite fit the tone of
2021's beginning and only really makes
an appearance near the end of the film
[Music]
and that's because the intro here is of
tranquil 1617 japan
the original doesn't have any flashbacks
at all it does however have
nightmares which both versions
incorporate and while both these
versions help set up the mortal kombat
tournament they go about it in two
wildly different ways
in 95 our protagonist is lou kang who
joins the tournament to avenge the death
of his brother chan at the hands of
shang soon
fun fact the actor who plays chan was
also the stunt coordinator on the
bachelor
cat
cat oh my those are kylie
fatality the 2021 version sets up our
new protagonist
cole young's bloodline and how he's
connected to the great warrior hanzo
hasashi who will become one of mortal
combat's most famous
fighters scorpion a huge difference
between these versions are how they
treat
scorpion and sub-zero in the original
these fighters are completely
one-dimensional and basically are just
there to look cool
and say their catchphrases get over here
in fact i don't think sub-zero says
anything at all whereas the 2021 version
has them completely fleshed out with
backstories that mesh into the greater
plot
you may notice hanzo here carrying these
buckets of water which are the same type
of buckets liu kang uses to defeat
sub-zero in the original we also get our
first close-up of scorpion's iconic
spear tip in the original it has more of
an organic quality while here it's made
of steel and more faithful to the game
we also see that it's johnny cage
fighting scorpion here and johnny's
absence from the 2021 version is one of
the biggest differences between the two
films
however we do find out cole is on his
way to hollywood in search of johnny at
the end in the original we see johnny on
set with a director who looks
suspiciously like steven spielberg hey
he might even be on the set of citizen
cage which we see a poster of near the
end a play on words of citizen kane the
1941 classic
notice how we don't see his face here
likely because they haven't cast him yet
raiden's role in the 2021 version is
way more hands-off than it is in the
original it's also taken a lot more
seriously
the fate of billions will depend upon
you
sorry raiden is the protector of earth
realm and he feels a lot more human in
the original as opposed to the
constantly glowing eyes of the 2021
version his powers are also vastly
expanded but that has likely more to do
with the advancement in visual effects
more than anything else
we see this with other characters as
well like liu king's fireball
and dragon apparition or sub-zero's ice
wall the closest we get to liu kang
having supernatural powers in the
original is the final blast he gives to
shang soon
characters like sonia never even get
powers in the original unless you count
her death by vagina move
the 2021 version gets a lot of the
exposition out of the way by showing
this title card explaining how shang
soon is one mortal kombat victory away
from being able to take over earthrealm
in the original this is all done through
dialogue from raiden the main difference
here however
is this talk about bloodlines and
prophecy which are
entirely new the 95 version dabbles a
bit with liu kang and destiny but
there's no mention of a
prophecy and outworld during the daytime
something you don't see in the original
although both versions
do visit this realm the new version
shows what appears to be shang soon's
throne
in the original the fighters battle him
in his castle which isn't depicted in
the
2021 version we do however get these
cloaked citizens of outworld
just like the original and a giant stone
statue of prince goro
some of you may forget but jax is
actually in the original for a total of
10 seconds literally i
i counted trust me sonia i trust one
person on this planet jack
you're talking to her here his character
is way more fleshed out having become a
champion himself after tracking down a
target with his partner sonia blade in
brazil
and obtaining his dragon mark his
shotgun is also way more beefed up
unlike the original these dragon marks
play a large role in the new version
they designate who will become a
champion
and who can unlock something known as
arkana this concept was never discussed
or shown in the original but it's what
locks one's powers and is different for
each individual shang soon tasks
sub-zero with tracking down
and killing earth's champions the ones
with this mark unlike the original shang
tsun doesn't invite them to participate
in a battle on his secluded island he
decides to break the rules established
by the elder gods
not mentioned in the 2021 version is his
allegiance to shao khan the emperor we
do see a statue of him
at the end of the 95 version he makes a
brief appearance setting him up as the
main villain for mortal kombat
annihilation but
oh god we we won't get into that
i've seen everything while the original
takes us to exotic locations like
southeast asia the new version
introduces us to the beauty of
gary indiana sonia here acts as mrs
exposition teaching us more about the
tournament and how the dragon marks work
we even get a glimpse of what could be
the character nighthawk not featured in
either versions however there is one
line of dialogue in the original that
does
mention him you're going to need a
seeing eye
soon tasmalina was sending out saizoth
also known as
reptile he looks a lot better here than
he does in the original
molina isn't in the original she's a
genetic experiment created by shang soon
and an adopted daughter of the emperor
xiao khan that makes her stepsisters
with princess katana
who we do see in the original we might
not see her in the 2020 version but we
definitely do see katana's iconic steel
fans in the background of raiden's
temple cole finds out that sonia has
kano chained up in the original she
chases him to shang tsung's island jax
and sonia worked together as part of the
special forces an organization created
by the us government to bring down the
black dragon and red dragon clans
kino is the leader of the black dragons
which steal into legal arms trades
among other things when we first meet
him in the original he already has his
iconic red eye the one with silver
plating
well in this version he learns this
ability as part of his
arcana although he does have a red eye
in the original we
never see him use it there kano ends up
joining forces with cole and sonia for a
short time and even uses his trademark
heart rip out fatality
which originated from the video game
something we don't see in the original
in fact the word fatality which has
become synonymous with the game
only is spoken once in both movies once
when shang tsung sucks the soul out of a
guy who loses to liu kang and once when
kung lao brutally severs natara in half
which i can't even show
or else my video will get demonetized
upon arriving at raiden's temple were
introduced to kung lao in the original
this name is only mentioned once kung
lao being an ancient ancestor of liu
kangs this kung lao is named after the
same ancestor and it's hinted at that
liu kang and kung lao could be
cousins a fun addition to the 2021
version is when liu kang challenges the
champions to test their might a mini
game found in the original video game
but never mentioned in the original film
speaking of luke kang we learned more
about his background in the 2021 version
like how he was an orphan picked up by
raiden this isn't really delved too
deeply in the original and more focus is
placed on his relationship with his
brother chan
something not mentioned in the new
version shang soon tests some more
memorable mk characters with defeating
the champions
these characters aren't seen in the
original and include natara cabal
and general raikko most notable among
them is cabal who has history with kano
also being a member of the black dragon
clan
it was kano who healed cabal and gave
him his respiratory mask which he calls
an
iron lung in the new version kino ends
up double-crossing the champions by
destroying raiden's staff which seems to
be protecting the temple this staff is
never seen in the original meanwhile
while cole goes back home he's attacked
by goro
in the original goro was a one million
dollar animatronic suit requiring over a
dozen puppeteers to operate
there are full scenes with him having
dialogue as well in the new version he's
basically in one scene to fight coal
with the purpose of cole discovering his
arcana
he's a bit more green in tone and
completely cgi
cole ends up killing goro with his
newfound power while in the original
he's killed by johnny cage after falling
off a cliff but i want to hear
which goro version you guys like more in
the comments below
kung lao says the iconic flawless
victory line here while in the original
that line is only spoken by shang soon
sonia ends up killing kano stabbing him
through the
eye with a garden gnome and i wonder if
he'll be resurrected in future sequels
with that new
iron eye plate lukang's fight with cabal
has him using his trademark bicycle kick
move while this same move is performed
by him against
reptile in the original cole is tasked
with taking on sub-zero but is helped by
his ancestor scorpion who has emerged
from the depths of hell in the original
scorpion transports johnny cage to a
hell type location where they fight he
even uses his skull fire breath move
which we see
in action in both versions with sub-zero
defeated
scorpion says he is now free and shang
soon is set up to be a recurring villain
swearing he'll bring armies next time
they see
each other in the original shang soon
dies at the end with a franchise opting
to focus on xiao khan in the sequel
warner brothers is currently waiting to
see whether or not this reboot is a
success and the actor who played
sub-zero has already signed on for four
more mortal kombat movies
should the studio decide to continue
with the franchise so it looks like if
the movie does well
sub-zero won't be the only thing that
survives thanks for watching everyone
check out my mortal kombat ending
explained video for an even deeper
analysis of the story
and make sure to like subscribe and
share this video for more bad takes you
can always follow me on twitter
and instagram thingstoryt until next
time remember
daddy loves you very much